so when we're talking about trust for
the eye we hear about these five pillars
right awareness robustness
privacy explainability and transparency
so what is all of this
you're right actually there are you know
at this point in time we usually
talk about five different pillars but
this now keep in mind that this is a
fast evolving space this field is
is changing um rapidly but at this point
we usually talk about
fairness robustness privacy
explainability and transparency
let's maybe talk about each of them
quickly fairness is probably obvious it
is to make sure that the
models are not behaving in a biased way
now it may actually start the challenges
start way before a model is built it
might be understanding if the data
itself is biased
if it is how do you deal with that when
you breathe when you build a model
how do you make sure that the model is
not
systematically giving an advantage or a
disadvantage to a certain
group and and the definition of the
group varies by industry by use case
it could be based on sensitive
attributes like age and gender and
ethnicity but
may not be limited to any of those you
want to make sure that
the system is not um consistently
favoring one over the other in an unfair
way
robustness you want to make sure that
your your models
behave well um yes in in
in exceptional conditions how do you
make sure that the model
performance is good over time
what is happening with with the
effective
data drift or for example in the context
of the
of the pandemic we know that customer
customer behavior has changed you know
customer patterns have changed
customer touch points have changed is
your model
still behaving as expected or if if it
is not
can you at least have an understanding
of how the model behavior is changing
how data is drifting how accuracy is
drifting etc
privacy can you make sure that the model
the data
the model that is built off of that
model the insights from that model
they are all um that the the model
builder owns
and retains control of those insights
and how do you do this not just as in
terms of consumption of the output of
the model but across the life cycle
how do you make sure that data
protection rules are in place
through the model building testing
validation
and monitoring stages explainability
is probably pretty obvious how can you
explain the behavior of a model why was
someone approved for a loan
why was someone rejected when somebody
applied for
for for a job and that person was
selected but someone with very similar
qualifications
applied that person was rejected can you
explain the behavior
to the end user or to a decision maker
transparency you want to be able to
inspect
everything about a model can you
understand all the facts
surrounding the model who built it what
data is being used
what algorithms what packages are being
used
who approved it uh who validated it all
all of these aspects of the model
facts about the model should be easily
available just like you know you have
you buy a
food product and there is a there's a
label on it you know it has the
nutritional facts
when was it manufactured where was it
manufactured all of that
just like that for a model you should be
able to get the facts of that model very
quickly
so these i would say are sort of the
fundamental pillars of trustworthy ai
the challenge is making sure these can
be
done in a systematic way regardless of
what tools are used to build the models
and where the models are deployed
so john in the recent past we have seen
that as
ai systems were new to a lot of
organizations
organizations have very recently adopted
such
large-scale ai applications or systems
in their workflow
and that's where we started seeing these
side effects of ai right and
that's where we pinpointed that hey like
these were some of the aspects which we
need to target
to make sure that ai doesn't have an ill
effect on the community or doesn't have
a ill effect on it
on an entire perspective so when we see
that
organizations are facing such challenges
when they are
seeing such uh like roadblocks with
respect to building trust for the ai
what is the recommended methodology on
making sure that building such ai
systems or like building such
trusted ai systems is easily done
throughout
different business units of the
organization and doesn't surely
you know uh it doesn't really streamline
to just one
particular department or team how can we
make it a big thing and how can an
entire organization
uh productionalize this streamlined work
so actually uh you know you're talking
about um expanding this across our
company sort of
setting up this governance framework and
that was one of the patterns we talked
about
many companies may not start there but
they may start with one of the other
patterns we talked about which is
let's start with assessment or building
out a new use case a new application
that follows trustworthy i principles
but yeah
some companies may want to look at a
top-down approach and
and set up the governance framework um
taking in
into account that there are multiple
streams of
data science and ai activities going on
concurrently
but in all of these you know regardless
of which approach you take i think
three elements need to come together uh
and i would say these these are these
three elements are technology
people and process technology is
probably obvious
uh we need to have guardrails across
each of the stages of the life cycle
when you're working with data how do you
check for bias in the data how do you
correct that
that's a that's a guardrail at the data
exploration
time uh when you're building the model
you need a you know you need a guardrail
in place for model building
for checking the robustness of the model
uh for providing
an explanation in development time
you need a guardrail um which which will
allow you to go
into valid through validation into
deployment and you need an outermost
guard where you think of it as a
one-time guardrail
which can continue to do monitoring of
your model
and look at how it is behaving against
thresholds whether the thresholds are
being breached etc
now so technology provides these
guardrails
for all of the different five pillars
that we talk about
now technology in itself is not
sufficient that's why i was mentioning
people and
process people because you need a set of
skills to come together it is not just
data science skills
the ml ops paradigm requires you to have
the operational skills come together
with
data science skills you might have risk
and compliance
expertise coming into the picture you
might have business
analysts and business stakeholders
coming into the picture
and so on so the right level of
expertise
um personas who are collaborating to
achieve this common goal
is important and then finally process in
a process that term process
you know people may not always like that
but the reality is you need a set of
best practices for each stage of the
life cycle
whether it is coping and building um or
it is validation
or deployment or monitoring over time
you need a set of best practices
so technology people
best practices coming together make it
possible to
loot trustworthy ai at scale and
operationalize it
great uh thank you so much john like it
was very insightful for
me because to understand kind of ai
systems we build
from understanding it from data science
perspective to how it can be
productionized
and run successfully in these large
organizations
it is very important that organizations
are responsible to the people who are
using it right
so it was it was really insightful that
we got to learn so many different things
from you
in the meanwhile i feel like there's a
lot of other resources which is
available for us to dig deeper
and learn about fairness robustness
transparency privacy and explainability
so uh everyone who's watching this you
can find the right
resources in the description below and
soon we'll be
posting more series of videos talking
deeper into each of these pillars
thank you so much